a sharp warning from the white house
tonight that a russian invasion of
ukraine could happen at any moment
canada joined several other nations
today urging its citizens to leave
ukraine now top u.s security officials
have laid out what a russian attack
could look like starting with an aerial
bombing campaign
jackson proskow joins us now from
washington jackson what more do we know
tonight
hi eric the white house insists that it
does not believe vladimir putin has made
a final decision on an invasion but the
tone today was unmistakable president
biden's national security adviser told
reporters that russia is in position to
mount a major military campaign any day
now and it could happen while the
olympics are still ongoing in addition
to urging americans to leave within the
next 24 to 48 hours they warned no u.s
military personnel will step onto
ukrainian soil to assist with evacuating
citizens in the event of an invasion the
u.s embassy continues its drawdown of
staff and there is growing concern that
a bloody assault beginning with missiles
and air strikes and bombings could be
the first salvo in any russian attack it
could take a range of different forms
but i want to be equally clear that one
of those forms
is a rapid assault on the city of kiev
that is a possible
line of attack course of action that the
russian forces could choose to take now
tonight we're learning that the u.s is
ordering an additional 3 000 troops to
poland that's on top of the nearly 2 000
dispatch there last week they are not
meant to fight russia in ukraine but
rather to deter any advance on nato
members today there was an 80-minute
long phone call between the u.s canada
and european allies the white house
insists they're all united and ready to
levy sanctions and other countermeasures
against vladimir putin and his inner
circle if needed but eric officially
they aren't giving up on diplomacy yet
and the white house expects that
president biden will speak with putin by
phone this weekend
thanks jackson jackson proskow in
washington tonight